all day they queued to give blood
residents of Gdansk doing what they
could to help the man who'd served as
their mayor since 1998 but they could
not save him
doctors confirmed the mayor has died
they were unable to save him after
everything that happened to him he will
rest for eternity with God
[Applause]
Pavel adamovich was attending a concert
for Poland's largest Christmas
fundraising event part of an annual
national campaign to raise money for
medical equipment for hospitals he was
stabbed in the stomach by a 27 year old
man who'd accessed the stage with the
help of a media badge and who shouted in
front of hundreds of onlookers that he'd
been wrongly imprisoned by the former
government animal which his party he
shouted that he'd spent five years in
prison because of the Civic Platform
opposition party this is what I was able
to hear and then my daughter said he was
holding a knife right after that we left
adamovich was well known for his liberal
attitudes a supporter of LGBT and
minority rights in Poland's increasingly
Riven political landscape me Hal George
in ski his deputy editor-in-chief of one
of Poland's major broadsheets I think
that everybody will ask the question
what what was really the reason was it
so no was it only a the problem of a one
man who decided to commit a crime or was
it the atmosphere the temperature of
debate the hate speech which you can
find in social media
European council head Donald Tusk is
traveling back to his home city of
Gdansk to honor his murdered friend as
people across Poland paid tribute
tonight to a popular politician taken
from them in this senseless and
appalling way Diana Magnay Sky News
Moscow